the UK's keep calm and carry on approach
to the coronavirus is in sharp contrast
to many other countries France Germany
and several other EU nations have banned
large gatherings of people and as
Italians woke up to a countrywide
lockdown the tightest restriction since
the Second World War it was business as
usual at Britain's Cheltenham horse race
meeting the event drawing tens of
thousands of visitors the differences
are stark in Italy Syria our football
matches went ahead but without any fans
well in the UK's premier league stadiums
were packed although players did have to
forego the traditional pregame handshake
the British government says it's putting
science at the heart of all coronavirus
planning it's resisted introducing
checks and airports and banning public
gatherings saying there's very little
scientific evidence the moves will help
instead the government's promoting a
phased approach contain delay research
and mitigate we remain in the container
phase of the outbreak but watching what
is happening around the world our
scientists think containment is
extremely unlikely to work on its own
and that is why we are making extensive
preparations for a move to the delay
phase the main strategies based on
stalling the peak of the virus until the
summer where they'll be less strain on
the country's Health Service however
experts now warn the virus will change
pace in a matter of days requiring
action so we are now very close to the
time probably within the next 10 to 14
days when the modelling would imply we
should move to a situation where we say
everybody who has even minor respiratory
tract infections or a fever
should be self isolating for seven days
afterwards the call for calm hasn't been
entirely heeded supermarkets have been
stripped of toilet paper and hand
sanitizer as people stockpile for a
crisis on the one hand you feel like
you're getting information saying not to
worry but then you also are wondering if
people are downplaying it thought to
cause panic
I think the big trouble is is knowing
what to believe from whom in the
government's worst case scenario 80% of
the country could fall ill the question
is whether Britain will look back at
this time and asked whether anything
could and should have been done sooner
Nev Barker al-jazeera London